بعض دول تغير مقرات عواصمها احيانا لتنقل
قرار سياسي الى اكثر مناطقها شهره او
لاسباب اقتصاديه وجغرافيه او حتى بسبب
زحام المروري غير ان اندونيسيا الواقعه
جنوب شرقي اسيا مجبره على فعل ذلك بسبب
غرق العاصمه الحاليه
تدريجيا جاكارتا صاخبه مشكلاتها كثيره
الاقتضاض اولها حيث يعيش نحو عشره ملايين
شخص في مساحه لا تتجاوز
660 كيلومتر مربعا يعيش ضعفهم اي 20 مليون
اخرين بالمنطقه المحيطه بالعاصمه حاجه
سكان جاكارتا للمياه النظيفه تدخل ضمن
المشاكل الاكبر فقيامهم بحفر الاف الابار
غير القانونيه جعل الاراضي اقل استقرارا
كما ان بحر جاوا المحيط بالعاصمه بدا
يرتفع تدريجيا بسبب ذوبان الجليد القطبي
العائد للتغيرات المناخيه اذا عوامل
اجتمعت المدينه يقع 40% منها تحت مستوى
سطح البحر باتت تغرق بما يعادل نحو قدم
واحد كل عام اذا مهمه الانقاذ المستحيله
اوجدت خططا لتخفيف الضغط عن عاصمه البلاد
تتمثل ببناء عاصمه اخرى هذه العاصمه تسمى
تارا العاصمه التي تبنى حاليا على اراضي
كانت خاليه بالكامل في مورينيو تقع على
بعد حوالي 1300 كم من العاصمه الحاليه
الرئيس الاندونيسي او وعد بان افتتاح
العاصمه الجديده سيتم العام المقبل وانها
ستكون نموذجا للتحديث البيئي ومحايده
كربونيا خلال عقود قليله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات